nuit du 11 au 12 juin 1917 dans une
réserve à betteraves dans la ferme du
jeûne est à mes yeux un petit village de
l'aisne cinq hommes cinq soldats
attendent dans cette réserve à
betteraves dans la nuit du 11 au 12 juin
1917 ces cinq hommes attendent la mort
c'est ça comme sur les combattants c'est
ça comme se sont battus depuis trois ans
et maintenant ils viennent d'être
condamnés à mort par le conseil de
guerre condamnés à mort pour mutinerie
c'est le président de la république
raymond poincaré qui le premier a
baptisé l'année 1917 l'année trouble et
trouble en effet parce que vraiment on
ne sait plus on ne sait plus où on en
est ç'a commencé en janvier quand le
président des états unis wilson a
proposé une paix sans victoire ça a
continué quand le nouvel empereur
d'autriche charles premier a commencé
des pourparlers pour une paix séparée
pour une paix de compromis ça a continué
surtout au mois de mars
quand tout à coup la révolte a éclaté à
petrograd on a balayé le régime tsariste
et d'ailleurs huit jours après nicolas 2
abdiqué et on comprend on sait déjà que
la russie tsariste la nouvelle russie
plutôt quittera bientôt la guerre
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer toutes
ses divisions qui sont à l'est et bien
ils reviendront à l'ouest l'année
troubles bien sûr en avril les états
unis entrent dans la guerre bonne
nouvelle mais quand seront ils en mesure
d'acheminer des hommes d'acheminer des
matériels du matériel pas avant
des mois l'année troubles surtout en
avril 1917
parce que l'offensive nivelle a échoué
on en parlait depuis des mois des
semaines de cette offensive nivelles on
disait que ce serait la fin que les
[ __ ] nom pouvait plus qu'on rentrerait
dans comme dans du beurre alors l'espoir
tout à coup c'est élevé oui l'espoir
et puis on en était venu à la défaite la
plus effroyable des défaites à une
hécatombe inutile et c'est après juste
après l'offensive nivelle très peu de
temps après que des régiments au front
avait commencé à se mutiner mutinerie
oui et c'est pour crime de mutinerie que
la dans la réserve à betteraves de cette
ferme de masi dans l'aisne
cinq soldats attendent la main cinq
soldats parmi lesquels un caporal le
seul caporal et ce caporal s'appelle
vincent mollien pourquoi vous raconter
ce soir l'histoire de vincent moulle ya
d'abord parce qu'elle est exemplaire
ensuite parce qu'il se trouve que
vincent moulias est vivant oui il est
sûrement à 91 ans le seul survivant de
tous les condamnés pour l'exemple
et voyez-vous dimanche dernier j'étais
près de lui dans sa petite maison d'une
assiette le village d'une assiette dans
les landes à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de dax et j'étais là dans sa
toute petite maison où il était avec sa
femme verte avec ses enfants
et là bon pied bon oeil l'un sans molia
à 91 ans il a les cheveux encore noah
une belle moustache et puis un regard
malicieux ans il a un petit peu perdu la
mémoire mais il se souvient de tous les
cantiques que le curé l'abbé verdier lui
apprenez quand il était petit puis aussi
des chansons un petit peu plus leste
qu'il a apprises pour régiment et à la
guerre oui c'est andré curculosse un
journaliste qui m'a conduit la cure
klaus et le premier qui en 1968 et
réunit les souvenirs de vincent moulias
j'ai passé une journée avec lui et j'ai
écouté un document précieux une bande
une bande magnétique 8h qu'à
l'initiative de son gendre mouly a
enregistré en 1970 et à travers cette
écoute c'était une vie qui s'écoule est
devant moi une époque qui surgissait et
surtout une incroyable aventure
on avait parlé de moulias dès 1934 dans
le crapouillot le crapouillot qui
faisait un numéro spécial sur les
mutineries pour la première fois le nom
de moulis à des imprimés et puis un
certain nombre d'historiens ont cité son
nom parmi les victimes des mutineries
you avec une exactitude très relative
deux historiens en 1965 imprimés
tranquillement que mouly avaient été
fusillés
et puis l'année dernière est paru un
livre un livre de pierre durand il
s'intitule vincent moulias les pelotons
du général pétain j'ai lu ce livre
je dois dire que c'est un très beau
livre c'est un admirable travail
d'historien une très belle enquête mais
c'est aussi une sorte de poème en prose
sur la guerre sur une vie dans la guerre
et à travers la guerre je dois dire que
si je n'avais pas lu ce grand livre je
n'aurai pas à mon tour
suivi l'itinéraire de vincent mouillard
il y aurait huit ans alors vincent
moulias qui s il n' assiette ce petit
village où j'étais dimanche dernier et
il est né en 1888 père inconnu
mr journalières un frère joseph une
enfance très très pauvres mais pas
malheureux il ya la mer qui l'adorent et
puis il ya le curé l'abbé verdier
personnage pour en couleur puis l'abbé
verdier gronde facilement mais il aime
beaucoup le petit vincent peut-être pas
justement parce qu'il n'a pas de père
alors en tout et pour tout il va aller à
l'école huit mois entre huit et neuf ans
le miracle c'est qu'il apprendra à lire
et à créer et puis les années qui coule
il travaille très tôt bien sûr
puissent-elles service militaire à pau
au 18e et puis après le service
militaire il trouve du travail à dax à
l'hôtel de l'europe
il est plongeur c'est pas malheureux
mais il n'a pas le temps de souffler
beaucoup entre le service militaire et
la guerre parce qu'elle arrive la guerre
est un beau matin il y a les petites
affiches blanches sur les mieux le dax
il part juste le temps d'aller embrasser
la mer moulée à anne assiette
elle plaît à la mer moulias mais l'abbé
verdier l'avait verdier dit dans la
presse allemande dans les journaux
allemands
on a dit du mal de lourdes alors c'est
sûr la vierge ne permettra pas que ces
gens-là gagné la guerre et moulis à
étapes aussi jours à pau le temps d'être
habillé et puis comme beaucoup de monde
à cette époque là le chemin de fait en
gare de pau les wagons à deux wagons de
marchandises bien sûr la fameuse
inscription hommes 40 chevaux 8
en long et on part l'effort de l'est
et puis ensuite le nord avesnes le
baptême du feu le 23 juin place en
mouillage s'en souviendra toute sa vie
tant des choses qu'on n'oublie pas parce
qu'on a beau faire l'exercice pendant
trois ans au service est pas la même
chose
on avance là quel temps aune des
pantalons rouges on s'avance dans les
blés et vincent molly à dira que ce
qu'il ait peiné le plus eu les paysans
des landes c'est qu'on avance et
justement dans des blés mûrs et dans une
moisson qui n'est pas fait je leur fais
broker à ces paysans et s'attire les
shrapnel les obus les balles qui
sifflent épiler copag étant ça ça fait
de l'effet et on avance la baïonnette et
on avance et on survit et c'est l'entrée
en belgique les villages les belges
vive la france et puis des réflexions en
voyant ce régiment qui s'avance à ben
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont petits et
d'explications buisson des gens du midi
charleroi deux jours ça n'a l'air de
rien charlois un mot c'est l'enfer déjà
le premier en faire de la grande guerre
il est là dans cet enfer vincent moulias
satan des pertes terribles ira le soir
le capitaine terrible mais on tient un
moment contre la pression allemande et
puis c'est la retraite
molina est à l'arrière-garde de temps en
temps fait face aux allemands genou en
terre on tire un moment un obus
explosent à deux mètres de moulis il est
entièrement enseveli dans la terre ils
en seraient étonnés d'être vivant et
voir grand allemand qui courent vers lui
la baïonnette pointé la barrette qui le
frappe en plein visage
il sent le fer de l'acier dans sa joue
mais il a lui aussi une baïonnette et
l'enfance dans le ventre de l'autre qui
tombe avec un crime affreux et
s'aperçoit que le sang qui coule de
partout où il allait l'ajout coupé en
deux il rampe dans un champ de luzerne i
se fait lui-même un pansement et puis
s'en va tant bien que mal rejoindre les
copains et qu'est ce qu'ils voient à
l'homme par terre c'est son capitaine
grièvement blessé il le charge sur ses
épaules il le ramène dans les lignes et
pour cette action d'éclat il est nommé
caporal les pions l'envoie à saint
brieuc à l'hôpital se faire soigner et
vraiment s'il y en a un qui est fier de
son galon de l'aisne c'est vincent
mollir et puis guérir paris l'état la
marne
là aussi c'est sérieux la marque quand
le régiment se reforme à beaurieux sûr
qu'un sans amis à la plus que 500 on a
perdu les deux tiers mais on la gagne
cette bataille de la marne on la gagne
et c'est ce qui sauve tout et on lui
donne une permission à l'assiette la mer
moulias l'avait verdier et puis bertha
oui je n'ai pas encore parlé de berthe
c'est une petite du village d'une
l'aiment bien berthe puis elle aime bien
la samba alors le dimanche quelques fois
d'aller danser ensemble avant la guerre
ma femme on s'était pas causer comme on
dit hélas cette fois bon ça dure pas
longtemps les permissions à l'heure
vincent il parle à la berthe et la
berthe est bien contente et on est
fiancée et on décide qu on se mariera à
la fin de la guerre roi c'est pour
bientôt ça peut pas durer quand c'est
possible elle voilà reparti en octobre
c'est dira-t-il l'attaquent la plus
cruelle qui les connaît et puis vient
l'hiver et le 18e régiment d'infanterie
comme des dizaines des centaines de
régiments s'enfouit dans la tête
et oui les tranchées ça commence et ça
va durer jusqu'au bout l'étranger alors
les tranchées oui un mot les tranchées
mais qu'est ce que c'est les tranchées
alors oui il ya des photos vous en avez
peut-être vu il y avait des photos dans
les magazines de l'époque dans
l'illustration meetic magnifique
l'étranger sublime
c'était comme tracées au cordeau avec
des parapets merveilleux des sacs de
sable bien rangés au dessus des créneaux
pour tirer puis des portes on entrait il
y avait une pièce avec les tables délit
ça existe et s'est rangé parce qu'il ya
des photos disons que ça existe et
surtout pour les journalistes et surtout
pour les hommes politiques condamnés au
front les autres c'était pas ça les
autres c'était des trous creusés dans la
terre est souvent pas si profondément
qu'on ne le croit
c'était des défauts ses actifs plus ou
moins consolidé à mesure que les mois
passent et et c'était surtout la boue
oui dans les belles photos
l'illustration qui a des caillebotis par
terre pour construit pas les pieds vous
pensez qu'il y avait des caillebotis
partout pas du tout y amène à hbos alors
la boue ont enfoncé jusqu'aux suivent
souvent jusqu'aux mollets et on vivait
dans l'homme ont mangé en ont tiré dans
l'âme
ce soir on se coucher par terre dans
cette boue
et puis
évidemment l'hiver cette boue s'est
solidifiée
oui bien sûr mais il faisait froid
l'hiver et tonelli vers 14-15 abominable
l'hiver 14 15 et puis surtout on n'est
pas préparé on n'a pas d'équipement rien
n'a été prévu
alors on crève de froid et des milliers
et des milliers de soldats en enlevant
leurs chaussures le matin trouvent leurs
pieds gelés les doigts de pieds quittant
après ça s'est un petit peu arrangé on a
donné des couvertures pour les hivers
suivants des lainages des cache-nez
capote
n'empêche la nuit imaginez la nuit
quelquefois par -20 -30 pendant l'hiver
16-17 il a fait moins 30 et là on est là
dans le froid on tient le fusil on
l'attend au moins si on était sûr qu'on
va se réjouit qu'on allaite réchauffer
le lendemain pas question on reste des
jours et des jours et des jours et des
nuits et des nuits et des nuits au moins
si on pouvait boire quelque chose de
chaud manger quelque chose de chaud pas
question il ya l'homme soupe ou lyon
l'appelle l'homme soupe qui arrive avec
ses bidons pour le ravitaillement
condition qu'il arrive parce que comme
fatalement il passe à découvert il ya
toujours des lascars en face pour faire
le coup de feu ça les amuse et puis il
faut dire que les français font la même
chose sur l'homme soupe allemand alors
on fait un carton l'homme souple il
arrive pas alors on attend le prochain
mais quoi qu'il arrive tout est froid et
c'est pas le pire le pire voyez vous
c'est l'odeur parce que entre les lignes
françaises et les lignes allemands et
des canards peut pas aller chercher
comment voulez-vous qu'on aille les
chercher
alors ça pue l'hiver ça va encore mais
l'été vous imaginez l'été la plante
abominable et puis il ya quand même dans
les tranchées des invités qui s'y trouve
bien y aller tous les uniformes de ces
hommes là sont grouillante
on appelle ça les totaux et ça procure
des démangeaisons insupportable
et puis à d'autres invités qui sont les
rares où ils sont chez eux les rats et
là partout ça grouille les rats ils ont
du cadavre à bouffer les rats alors
c'est pas mal alors ils ont tellement de
cadavres à manger que il ne distingue
plus les morts et les vivants alors
quand vous êtes couché deux le soir dans
la tranchée le combattant qu'est ce
qu'il fait et bien il semble hop la tête
il semble up les mains sans ça les rats
attaque les vivants les visages les
mains et tout ça c'est rien encore ya le
bruit il ya des faux ça ne cesse pas
pendant des jours et des jours et des
nuits et des nuits à devenir fou le cas
l'an qui tire qui tire qui tire à cette
nir les oreilles c'est épouvantable il y
faut subir et on n'a pas le droit de ne
pas subir
et puis enfin c'est au but son tir et il
arrive qu'ils atteignent leur but
paf au milieu la tranchée alors là c'est
l'horreur à l'état pur il ya ceux qui
sont là qui viennent de recevoir les
éclats d'obus
ils sont déchirés dépecé éclaté celui
qui est indemne reçoit tout à coup en
pleine figure la cervelle de son copain
à kiel par les cinq minutes avant et
puis surtout c'est au but ont fait
éclater la terre et on a l'impression
d'être tout à coup dans une sorte de
décharge
tout apparaît en même temps il ya les
vivants il est blessé qui hurle il ya
ceux qui viennent d'être tués
il ya aussi les cadavres de l'année
dernière qu'on avait enterré tant bien
que mal et qui surgissent de la terre
pour y puis à des vieilles boîtes de
conserve et pid et des casques percée et
puis des vieilles chaussures et puis des
eaux un fort et vivent là dans ces gens
et vivent là dedans
et puis même à certains jours et bien il
faut partir à l'assaut c'est l' attaque
on est là on attend on sait qu'on va
attaquer il ya le capitaine ou
lieutenant qui est là qui regarde
l'heure c'est leur hache en avant alors
on a des petites échelles pour sortir où
il arrive aussi souvent qu'il ya pas de
petites échelles et on sait on sait
parfaitement que les autres tirent la
mitrailleuse t il ya un feu roulant et
on sait que quand on aura sorti la
poitrine on sera en face de ce feu
roulant et pourtant vraiment il y en a
quelques fois qu'ils ne peuvent pas et
permettez moi d'évoquer un souvenir
personnel je pense à mon père officier
en 14-18 sur l'isère il était jeune
avocat avant la guerre et comme jeune
avocat tout à coup on lui a dit vous
allez porter l'accusation conseil de
guerre terrible on peut pas refuser non
plus et il est là il est obligé
d'accusés et mon père me disait mais
c'était affreux
il y en avait en effet qu'il ne pouvait
pas sortir et il s'est expliqué il me
disait mais mon lieutenant je vous jure
je ne pouvais pas ne pouvais pas et au
lieu d'accuser mon père te sens tu es
désespéré et il me disait jamais demandé
une tête
je n'ai pas de morts sur la conscience
comment ne pas les comprendre et tous
pourtant ce presque tous ils partent et
alors quand on lisait récit quand on les
entend on est là et on s'est dit c'est
pas possible ils ont supporté sa quatre
ans et on se dit et nous à leur place
est ce qu'on est sûr d'avoir pu en faire
autant est-ce que vous êtes sur ce que
je suis sur moi non alors c'est ça la
vie des tranchées et moulis à il est là
au milieu des autres y vit il n'est pas
plus fiers qu'un autre il supporte les
autres s'ils supportent y en a des
millions kim
alors il est sur la somme il est à
verdun sont presque tous passés à verdun
a causé roulement et à verdun les
blessés dans une attaque qui sortent 108
l'huile caporal moulias et sept autres
et c'est tout
fini il est blessé on le ramène c'est le
poste sanitaire à il faudrait parler du
post qualité il faudrait relire la vie
des martyrs de georges duhamel faisait
ce qui pouvait les médecins les
brancardiers il était même dé type
épatant mais il n'était pas suffisante
surtout au moment des attaques
on leur en ai tellement ils pouvaient
pas faire face alors les blessés
s'accumulent et dans la cour lâche
quelques fois grand-père sous la pluie
sur leur branca puis à côté il y avait
des soldes avec des gourdins à rassurer
vous c'était pas pour assommer les
blessés c'était pour assommer les rats
qui couraient entre les brancards et
alors on les a portés dans le poste
d'opération y avait des chirurgiens qui
a opéré 24 heures sur 24 qui en avait
tant vu qu' on aurait pu croire qu'il
était blasé ben non il n'était pas blasé
on leur apportait quelques fois des
débris humains tels que même était
effaré et puis avait des questions
cet homme qu'on la porte il a les deux
points coupe et ça va aller mon dieu
qu'est ce que tu fais dans le civil
sculpteur mon capitaine alors soigner
moulias ramener parce que dès qu'on est
gay rions pas pour sa rentrée il à
douaumont une belle rentrée et puis
c'est l'hiver l'hiver 16 17 le plus dur
de tous
les vins le café sont gelés le pain la
viande on les coupes à la hache ou à la
6c salivaires et on attend parce qu'on
se dit après verdun quand même bon les
arrêter à verdun est un rayon les aura
on les a vus alors bon maintenant on va
repartir du bon pied oui verdun ya eu un
million de soldats qui sont tombés des
deux camps un million enfin on les a eus
alors on va faire quelque chose au
printemps 17 oui tout le monde en parle
ayant un nouveau général il s'appelle
nivelles il a un plan et le moral très
haut dans les livres en saison on y
croit on se dit cette fois on va y aller
il paraît que les [ __ ] 30 à bout non
n'ont plus rien à manger en allemagne
c'est fini on va rentrer là dedans comme
dans du beurre
cette fois ça y est on est confiant et
l'offensive nivelle a lieu le 16 avril
1917 à 6h du matin de toutes les lignes
dans un grand cri en avant les hommes
partent à la ctaq 6h du matin
l'offensive nivelle
à cette heure la bataille est perdue on
le sait tout de suite
muglia et les siens n'ont pas charger le
le 16 mai seulement un peu plus tard
mais avant qu'une charge à craonne ils
savent que la bataille est perdue parce
que ça va vite sur le seront les
nouvelles surtout les mauvaises et on
sait que on n'a pas détruit les
mitrailleuses par exemple mitrailleuses
allemandes
on aurait dû les détruire l'artillerie
avant non les a pas les trucs et les
hommes ont foncé sur les mitrailleuses
ils sont courus vers les mitrailleuses
comme à l'abattoir les allemands tenus
on ne passe pas cette fois-ci et moulias
attend la table leur hache lui aussi
avec ses copains il est là dans sa
tranchée et toussant sous le masque à
gaz parce que maintenant en plus on est
obligé de porter des masques à gaz
le froid la pluie glacée on attend et
puis alors la soupe qui arrive un
mangeable raconte vincent moulin à vent
et un beau diable parce qu'elle est
piquée elle-même par les gaz en avant et
moulias dans son secteur ça marche pas
mal
trois kilomètres c'est beau 3 km mais ce
qui arrive au but et bien sont pas
nombreux enfin l'aïe un allégé succès et
le lendemain un ordre qui pourra le
moulias pour l'aider sommes allés
nettoyer la tranchée allemande qui est
là bon du moulias qui est volontaire
dans la tranchée on n'est pas chaud pas
de volontaires bon on diminue alors je
vais y aller tout seul alors il ya
bachacou un copain à du pays là bas je
te laisse avec moulias depuis longtemps
que liban palaisien avec toi bien jeune
jeune qui vient d'arriver
pourquoi est-ce qui dit qui va venir va
et vient bon on y va je vois le
troisième qui parle qui traverse le no
man's land qui descendent dans la
tranchée à demande apparemment il ya
personne dans la tranchée allemande tant
mieux alors il s'avance quand même
prudent tout à coup au détour d'un
parent à peine sentir et allemand volià
pointe sa baïonnette l'autre lève les
mains vouliez a pris la précaution de se
retourner en dix ans arrêtez-vous légale
d'approcher que quand vous demanderez le
l'autre semble-t-il connais un peu le
français camarades prisonniers alors il
dit ou fille tire on officieront va voir
et voilà notre 3 qui avance
j'entre dans une casemate ça doit être
une ancienne carrière parce qu'il ya des
colonnes tout les tous les 5 mètres et
tout à coup face à face avec un officier
allemand qui est en train de se raser
les trois fusils pointés l'allemand qui
lève les mains il se rend lui aussi
puis sort son portefeuille montre la
photo qui a trois enfants driving dead
ne me tuez pas prisonnier il continue à
avancer comme un autre endroit de la
casemate
et là il trouve cet officier allemand
qui sont autour d'une table autour d'un
grand gâteau les deux bouteilles de vin
blanc
ils se rendent prisonniers tout va bien
vous lui envoie le jeune va chercher des
renforts
puis on pousse les allemands vers le
haut de la tranchée les renforts
arrivent on les emmène dans nos lignes
et le capitaine et il est content il est
drôlement content le capitaine eddy
moulias caporal molia vous avez accompli
une action d'éclat
bon c'est dit moulian on accomplit une
action d'éclat il dit à bachot cloud dit
non et se sont compris il retourne à la
tranchée allemande de cendres dans la
casemate et bouffe le gâteau et bois le
meuble et au retour et bien molli à
effet croix de guerre reçoit la croix de
guerre sur le front des troupes cité
deux fois mouillé a craint alors
l'offensive nivelle a bien dû cheikh
total on sert non seulement front mais
on sait à paris et nivelles est
convoquée par le président de la
république poincaré par le président du
conseil ribot par le ministre de la
guerre pas levé et nivelles doit
s'expliquer et il sent planer sur lui
non seulement du scepticisme mais de
l'hostilité
on voudrait bien au gouvernement qu'il
s'arrête il ne veut pas s'arrêter
nivelles et quand un de ses généraux lui
fait un rapport en disant mais mon
général
l'hécatombe est terrible l'armée
française va disparaître toute entière
il répond la victoire est pour demain il
faut continuer il ya quelque temps de là
le député hiberner garat y parlera en
comité secret à la chambre des députés
il sait de quoi il parle hiberner garaï
parce que ce député est également
officier d'infanterie il a chargé
à la tête de ses troupes pendant
l'offensive nivelle et c'est le porte
le tableau qu'il fait est hallucinant il
montre les hommes qui courent vers les
mitrailleuses qui tournoient et tout à
coup alors il croit avoir passé les
lignes allemandes et bien il yad'autres
mitrailleuses allemandes qui leur tirent
sur le flanc est il dépassé chasseurs
ces fantassins qui tombe qu'ils savent
plus où aller ces sénégalais qui n'ont
plus de commandants qui sont là qui
grelotte et le tableau du bar nagra il
faut le lire il existe il a été publié
il a tiré des larmes je vous jure au
coeur le plus sec et j'imagine cet homme
à la tribune de la chambre les députés
qui écoute et nous savons qu'il a parlé
dans le silence le plus total
et peu à peu parmi les rangs des députés
sur tous les bancs ceux qui se lèvent
c'est une pitié immense pour ces soldats
qu'on a envoyés à l'abattoir pour rien
ceux qui se lèvent aussi c'est une
colère de plus en plus violente
alors si des députés qui n'y étaient pas
sont en colère imaginez les sentiments
de ces hommes qui étaient et on les
ramène vers l'arrière dans des camions
ils sont là debout dans le froid sur la
plateforme dans leur capote caparaçonnés
debout elle traverse des villes comme
epernay château thierry et les habitants
stupéfait entendent des cris peut jamais
depuis le 1er ou 14 ans n'a entendu il
crie ses hommes nivelles assassin nouvel
assassin vive la paix où ils vivent la
paix jamais l'armée française l'avait
poussé ce cri alors
on a fait pas mal d'études sur les
mutineries 1917 intéressante je pense
aux travaux de lieutenant colonel henry
carré ou de john williams mais il a
fallu attendre le grand travail de guy
pedro signé un universitaire qui a fait
sa thèse sur les mutineries juste que là
eh bien on n'avait pas le droit d'aller
dans les archives de la justice
militaire vous avez faut 50 ans pour les
archives dès que les 50 ont été achevés
guy pedranzini à consulter ces archives
et maintenant on a des chiffres et des
dattes et voyez vous on avait cru que
les mutineries commencé un peu plus tard
pas du tout elle commence le jour même
de l'offensive nivelle le 16 avril il ya
déjà l'abandon des abandons devant
l'ennemi le 17 il y en a et puis dans
les jours qui suivent encore et à mesure
qu'on avance le mouvement s'accélère
mutinerie à mourmelon-le-grand la
première grande mutinerie et puis
ensuite le 20 mai mutinerie à prouilly
200 hommes on prend à partie les
officiers on refuse de marcher on chante
l'internationale ses miches de ces
mutineries tourner court en général ça
ne dure pas très longtemps mais ce qui
est grave c'est qu'elle veut commencer
et puis il ya plus grave dans un corps
il ya un médecin un médecin militaire
très dur quand un homme déclare qu'il
est malade lui disent tu es un
stimulateur au front quand un homme est
blessé d'une méthode déjà guérie alors
ce médecin
on le reconnaît on entoure frappe et
trois gendarmes courageusement à courre
revolver au poing pour le dégager on se
rue sur les gendarmes ont les désarment
on les pousse faire des arbres qui sont
là où les paons et de semaine en semaine
de jour en jour de semaine en semaine le
mouvement s'accélère
bientôt des régiments des divisions
savez vous combien de divisions ont été
contaminées en tout donc combien de
divisions signale des mutineries dans 54
division la moitié de l'armée française
un moment donné paul-painlevé ministre
de la guerre dira à l'heure actuelle
entre le front et paris si jamais une
attaque allemande d'envergure se
produisait je ne dispose que de deux
divisions sur alors au milieu de cette
tempête
comment le 18e régiment d'infanterie le
régiment de vincent molia sera t-il
laissé à l'abri à l'écart akron le
régiment le 18e régiment a perdu 20
officiers 824 hommes il y a eu six ans
citations sur ses hommes sur les
survivants
le régiment a été citée à l'ordre de
l'armée on va lui donner la fourragère
des héros ses hommes
d'ailleurs ils sont presque tous des
héros on ne le dira jamais assez
alors on les envoyer au repos
le gros du régiment et à villiers en
faire le deuxième bataillon celui de
moulis a aidé dans un petit village de
masi gta mais il ya quinze jours
cap a beaucoup changé le village une rue
principale avec des maisons pas très
hautain étage propre clé une place qui
donne sur le canal de l'aisne un café
dans ce cas fige et se trouvaient des
jeunes gens qui connaissent encore la
grande guerre parce que dans ces
endroits là vous savez on n'oublie pas
facilement
puis j'ai rencontré madame du chéné une
vieille dame charmante et son frère
andré grêlé c'était eux qui étaient dans
la ferme
où la tragédie va se dérouler et voyez
vous on a des idées toutes faites comme
quoi l'histoire écrite c'est bien mais
l'histoire avec les témoins c'est mieux
encore faut-il en trouver encore et là
on en trouvait et voyez-vous mon idée
sur les cantonnements à l'arrière savait
que après l'enfer on les envoyait à
l'arrière je me disais au moins là il se
repose et il avait des chambres et
pouvaient chauffer pouvait se l'avait
déshabillée dormir tout leur saoul banon
penser monsieur me disait madame
duchesneau quand il est arrivé
bah on le mettait souvent dans des
granges que l'effroi dans ces grands
sports c'est palerme été qu'une branche
avait des portes vers 1 à claire-voie
encore heureux quand ils avaient de la
bague
alors pas question de se déshabille pas
question d'avoir chaud manon schultz pas
dans une grande course la veille avec la
rivière alors l'hiver on n'avait pas
envie d'aller dans la rivière de la
nourriture auprès eagle arriver non
monsieur
pas plus qu'au front y avait des retards
alors le repos et puis mais il est à 15
km du front alors ça tirait tout le
temps le bruit alors c'était ça le repos
alors il faut dire que quand ils sont
arrivés à masi n'était pas content les
officiels randy mais non a lancé
provisoire on ira plus loin bientôt et
puis attention on a des permissions a
des permissions travaux et on leur parle
mais on leur parle même de 25% de
permissions c'est beaucoup 25% de
permission à l'homme sur 4,6 par puis à
mesure que les heures et les jours
passent à metz on parle de 13% de
permissions puis 9% une permission alors
la trouve que c'est un peu fort on n'a
pas le droit de faire ce à quoi et quand
on lit les rapports aujourd'hui sur
cette affaire sur ses affaires et bien
on se rend compte que la sphère des
permissions a compté pour beaucoup dans
les mutineries
le jour de la pentecôte est bien le 20
mai jour de la pentecôte non c'est
plutôt pardon le 27 mai on fête la
journée dans le café de masi et puis
dans l'après midi à un bruit à bruit
dans le village
c'est ça la guerre c'est ça tous ceux
qui se sont battus vous le diront il ya
des bruits et qu'est ce que c'est le
bruit qui court c'est que le samson
samson le 168e qui doit monter en ligne
vient de se mutiner talent et surprend
pas ses soldats et savent qu'à des
mutineries partout et alors comme il
s'est mutinée qui ne veut pas monter en
ligne
c'est le 18e qui va monter en ligue 2
18e qui en vient à peine le 18e qui a
été écrasé par bret alors c'est la
colère tout à coup alors les hommes se
répandent dans le village donc partout
pour dans les ruines crie on n'ira pas
et puis on a tout à coup qui commence tu
chantes c'est la lutte finale
le grand soir c'est demain et les voilà
qui chante l'internationale et ils
défilent et moulias s'en souvient il
défile et là comme des fous épices où
l'ia se souvient il y avait des civils
avec le petit des femmes et il marche
dans la rue dans la grande rue du
village il s'avance savent pas où vivent
pu mettre des mitrailleuses aux issues
du village comme ça ils sont chez de
personnes les dérangera et puis on va
crever les pneus des camions comme son
parti rap & molly à la ddt et vincent
bouvier voilà vos liens il n'est pas
d'accord
ben non il n'est pas d'accord moi
vincent mouliens caporal pour avoir
sauvé mon capitaine mois vincent moulias
blessés à verdun
moi vincent molia croix de guerre sur le
front des trop pour avoir fait hui
officiellement prisonnier non non non
logement bah quoi cette guerre aux
fondus mollien on nous l'a imposé on n'a
pas voulu cette guerre alors quoi moi je
pense qu'il ya une guerre c'est fait
pour être gagné on va quand même pas
laisser laisser aller le kaiser se
pavaner sur les champs elysées à paris
et oui mondiale le caporal vincent
moulias pense toujours que la force
principale des armées c'est la
discipline et il n'est pas là il édifie
défile pas moulias il crie pas un moule
ya d'ailleurs au début de la révolte il
est au cantonnement des officiers parce
que on l'a chargé d'une répartition de
réserves de vivres écoles pagaille
éclate il ya l'officier qui dit mais oui
non là des munitions ici on a on a du
ravitaillement qui va garder tout ça y
est mort il ya dix mois et c'est pour ça
qu'il est au cantonnement
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne participent à
rien et puis voilà le capitaine lasserre
qui survient il est sous le capitaine
lasserre ils vont nous lier avec 10
commencé c'est vous voulez à habas vous
en avez fait belge vous et les vôtres
pardon mon capitaine du bo ya moi
j'arrive chez moi j'aurais été ici tu as
été tout seul ah bon dit rasséréné le
capitaine la serpent puis c'est comme ça
voulait aller me chercher mon ordonnance
bah vous voulez vous que je la trouve
mon capitaine ben dans le village
trouvait là moi j'en ai besoin
alors mondial pour la première fois il
est mêlé aux mutins trouve lors d'un an
ce qui est fin saoul d'ailleurs elle lui
dit dans le capitaine lasserre qui tu
réclames ou qui laisse capitaine deal
ordonnance que je le crève ou du moulias
pas de ça je retourne cantonnement et 10
pas du tout il ne dit rien sur les
menaces proférées par l'ordonnancé du
bon capitaine laisse ou alors on peut
rien en faire
mourad il a seulement on verra il en est
on ça fatigue les émotions alors
mouillart
qu'est ce qu'on voulait du face il se
couche il s'endort à l'aube ils se
réveillent plus personne dans la maison
les officiers sont partis
où on en est il sort il trouve des
gendarmes et des gendarmes partout puis
un capitaine de jean lamas qui
s'approche soupçonneux dit qu'est ce que
tu fais là qu'est ce que tu fais toi mon
capitaine moi j'étais chargé de garder
les munitions le ravitaillement vous
pouvez rentrer ils manquent de rien bon
très bien
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire caporal
bas je voudrais rejoindre la section je
sais pas où elle est bien venez avec
nous on va à beaurieux où l état major
on vous emmène il ya un camion il monte
dans le camion puis en route on voit des
des hommes isolés ans et puis le climat
de la veille l'exaltation est tombé sont
là à se dire mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a été fou qu'est ce qui va nous
arriver maintenant
et puis 1 à 3 contre charge en route qui
viennent d'aussi le mans monter dans le
camion puis on arrive à beaurieux c'est
le capitaine lasserre encore qui est là
qui les réceptionne et le capitaine de
gendarmerie d'ian vous en ramène 3 il
montre moulias et voilà le caporal
moulias qui a fait son devoir
montbron dilasser descendez pyla sur le
canal de l'aisne il ya cinq ans un champ
plus tôt qui était entouré de barbelés
ya des sénégalais qui veillent à
l'entrée puis à côté il ya un camp de
prisonniers qui est la plus anciens et
les trois sont poussés dans ce champ est
le capitaine la serbie bull y aller avec
les autres cas pourquoi elle avec les
autres ils sont prisonniers malheur moi
aussi moulias pourquoi prisonniers alors
ils ont des tentes ont qui dressent des
tentes il s'installe la nuit le
lendemain le lendemain quand ils se
réveillent moulias s'aperçoit qu'ils
sont 42 les soldats du xviiie qu'on a
été recherché un peu partout ils sont là
prisonniers mais enfin moi moulias
prisonniers mais comprend pas voulu
aller dit merci c'est bizarre qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui me veut le capitaine
lacets et puis à des allemands qui
arrive qui baragouine qu'est-ce qui se
passe
merde emilien pas content molly api
voilà qu'un que se ramène le sergent
major où il le connaît ça va s'expliquer
mais non parce que voilà l'état major
complet le général pak est pas content
le général pak est il passe au milieu
des hommes
il a l'air furieux ils voient mouly a
dit commencez-vous caporal molia vous
que j'ai cités il y à peine s'ils jouent
molia vous avez trahi votre drapeau au
lit à vous avez souillé l'honneur de la
france
je vous plains je voudrais expliquer
moulias mais comprenez quand on a pas
d'instruction on trouve pas les mots
pirat général alors dit rien muliplient
général s'en va on va les emmener en
camion jusqu'à crown maison de crâne et
là ils vont encore attendre
puis un beau matin vont venir on va
venir ont cherché 12
pourquoi 12 et bien parce que le 15 mai
1917 le général pétain a été nommé
commandant en chef à la place de
nivelles il était temps double mission
rétablir la situation militaire et
mettre fin à la crise du moral dans
l'armée pas facile alors pour le moral
pétain est confiant l'affairé grave at
il dit mais je pense en venir à bout
seulement faudra des exemples il faudra
que dans chaque corps mutinés il y ait
des exécutions sévérité dit pétain
sévérité pour que la répression soient
limités alors des ordres sont partis
dans toutes les unités
bon puisque le 18e s'est mutinée il faut
bien faire des exemples aussi dans le
18e mais voilà tout le régiment s'est
mutinée on peut pas juger un régime anti
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est un
officieux qui est une idée on n'a qu'à
en prendre 12 bah oui 12 mai comment les
choisir sont tous coupables de la même
manière et un autre à une idée mais on
n'a qu'à prendre dans les livrets
matricule ceux qui ont le plus de jours
de prison voilà une idée et on le fait
on a 12
non le dernier celui du caporal chrono
et voilà il
il proteste le caporal chrono j'étais
pas là moi le jour de la mutinerie
j'étais à 40 km il prouve bah oui ils
étaient 40 km c'est difficile de laisser
sur la liste alors on l'aurait il faut
un caporal alors on prend mouly et c'est
pourquoi le 7 juin ils sont conduits à
12 devant le conseil de guerre à messi
s'en souvient molia c'était une pièce
assez grandi pense que ça devait être
une salle d'école au fond une table un
colonel
quatre officiers de chaque côté à gauche
la plus apple
le commandant oliveri il connaît mouly
haye les deux gore au liberia marchand
de poisson à grand blanc à droite le
l'avocat commis d'office bien sûr le
lieutenant vivien les 12 e puis une
garde d'honneur casque en tête jugulaire
qui rend les honneurs
quand le tribunal entre le tribunal
salut tout le monde a su mais ça
commence
le cauchemar commence le colonel qui
interroge nom prénom matricule grade
caporal moulias vincent mon colonel
puis la sphère qui s'avance et puis un
peu mouillée à se rend compte qu'il y
ait un rapport qui l'accablent et ce
rapport et du capitaine lasserre pas
quoi mais enfin il poursuit ce capitaine
la serre mais qu'est ce que je lui ai
fait et puis les témoins qui défilent
pas mal de témoins 25 et moi donc un
soldat et puis des officiers le
commandant robert qui vient dix ans je
tiens à témoigner que molly a toute ma
confiance est un bras puis un autre
officier d'autres officiers qui dit jeu
dans tous les coups durs molly a été et
est le premier maintenait le moral de
tous les siens ça marche stimuli à qui
jubile puis voilà le capitaine la serre
alors là
au lieu à serre les poings tel capitaine
la série mal à l'aise il dit mon colonel
je tiendrai à rectifier un certain
nombre de termes de mon rapport écrit un
peu vite et l'accusateur oliveri il dit
mais il est très clair votre apport
capitaine mais oui la série mais en fait
je tiens à dire une chose moliets un
brave oui oui c'est fini
puis oliveri parle demande des têtes il
dit quand à moorea il a été l'un à l'un
des instigateurs de la révolte la preuve
c'est qu'il a insulté un sergent alors
moulias s'adresse c'est pas vrai
taisez-vous deal colonel et puis il ya
l'avocate il tire par la manche qui dit
c'est vous c'est moi qui dois parler
pour vous qui parle de ton vivien il en
garde un bon souvenir molia où il a bien
parlé mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
colonel lui a dit lieutenant pas de
longueurs inutiles et puis les
condamnations sur les 12 5 condamnations
à mort et moulis a dura plus tard qu'est
ce que vous voulez c'est teddy l avance
il en fallait 5
bon c'est tombé sur nous c'est tombé sur
moi
et le voilà maintenant dans cette
réserve à betteraves là-bas dans la
ferme
ils appellent ça une voûte et quand
madame du chéné son frère andré gall et
m'ont guidé et le fils aussi de madame
du chéné qui à la fin ils m'ont dit que
les trois voûtes du fonds où étaient
enfermés les condamnés n'existait plus
mais il existe encore une voûte au fond
à gauche qui ressemble très exactement
celle où il était here
quand on la voit on peut très bien se
rendre compte de ce qu'était les
conditions de leur captivité alors on
les a poussés là sous cette voûte et on
entre en l'odeur oui l odeur au front
puis à l'odeur là mais c'est pas la même
une odeur vraiment pas agréable
il y avait une sorte de boue j'admets
des détritus ce de betteraves
ça sent pas bon vous savez la boue de
betteraves alors il n'y avait rien pour
se coucher moulias qui dit avec ses mots
gendarmes darribère qui est là pour les
garder qui va coucher avec eux à
l'intérieur dire écoutez chef on va pas
dormir la danse et de la boue de la mer
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous lie à dix
derrière moi j'y peux rien écoutez il ya
du fil de fer dans la cour il ya des
pics et moi je veux bien faire à
treillage qu'on mettra de la pac dessus
on va consulter un lieutenant il est
d'accord rhodia confection le treillage
on installe des couche de paille qui
sont au moins le cul sec puisque uche
est là où il est tout à coup au moulias
voix au plafond dans la voûte en briques
une règle lumière tient en gardant mieux
vous savez on s'habitue à l'obscurité
voit une plaque en tint en tôle et
comprend comme le haut des voûtes et de
plain pied par derrière avec une longue
prairies c'est par là qu'on doit amener
les betteraves pour qu'elle tombe dans
l'arène intéressant faudra voir qui
s'endort
le lendemain matin il demande à léo
cabinet un gendarme la compagnie monte
l'escalier le voilà dans la prairie duo
c'est là que se trouve le cabinet et
rentre dans le cabinet puis un obus
explosent à 150 mètres gendarmes dib est
gros
muglia un chef je fais que commencer
débrouille toi l aile gendarmes ses
clips alors lui sort du cabinet il a
pris en bas un piquet qui restait du
triage du fil de fer il l'a cachée sous
sa tunique et maintenant ils soulèvent
la plaque de tôle et met en place le
piquer avec le fil de fer qui pend et
redescend vous dirai pourquoi il s'est
pavanée elle qu'à courir dans la prairie
c'est le plein de sentinelle figurez
vous qu'on les prend plein loriot
descend riante dans sa prison depuis
deux jours de nuit l'après midi du
troisième jour une explosion dans la
cour des cris le capitaine de
gendarmerie qui entre qui dit au
condamné
triste nouvelle trois de nos camarades
des tués par un obus
qu'est-ce qu'il veut ramasser les
morceaux voulu à cela veut dire mon
capitaine moi vous savez ça me fait plus
rien arriver et madame du chéné
aujourd'hui encore se souvient du
carnage il ya eu des blessés en plus et
elle se souvient de ce malheureux qui
est un éclat d'obus avaient emporté un
pied et le malheureux avait une idée ni
dfx iran paix dans la courbe porte trop
mais son pied
alors on a ramassé les morceaux au
moulias ramasser les morceaux rugby la
nuit la nuit encore en fait mme liam il
avait encore confiance parce qu'il se
disait bon quand même
on va on peut pas me tuer je vais être
graciée par ce que il y avait beaucoup
de grâce
il ya eu 500 autres parlent des chiffres
officiels il ya eu un peu plus de 500
condamnation à mort dans tous les
conseils de guerre de cette époque-là et
guy prêts dont une signée a montré qu'il
y avait 50 exécution donc forte
proportion de grâce en fait bien sûr ça
sont les chiffres officiels et il est à
peu près certain qu'il y a eu d'autres
exécutions des exécutions sommaires qui
ne sont pas dans les rapports
enfin par rapport aux condamnations
officielles celle de molière en était
une
et bien il y avait beaucoup de grâce et
c'est qu'ils y vont me brassier
et puis dans la nuit il est réveillé par
un piétinement des hommes qui prennent
position dans l'accord il écoute puis
l'entente de type qui part tu parles en
patois et c'est son patois moulias vous
comprenez tout le 18e et de pau la
région qu'est ce qu'ils disent y'en a
qui disent moi j'aurais jamais cru qu'on
me fasse faire une chose pareille et
lockheed et moi tu sais j'suis pas tiré
sûr il y aura un côté pu tirer en l'air
et comprend vous lire
c'est le peloton d'exécution qui est là
bon alors ça y est maintenant pas une
minute à perdre
ils se mêlent ils appellent le gendarme
darribère qui dort chef chef pas quoi
vous dire
qu'est-ce qui a cherché la colique
correa coliques chef veut aller au
cabinet au tu nous emmerdes moulias en
chef au bon livre est d'arriver à
l'islam qui vous la partie sans qui
rejoint les autres gendarmes qui sont là
qui bavarde avec eux un instant et puis
moulias qui lui doucement dire la porte
vers lui la referme tourner la clé dans
la serrure
le gendarme darribère est enfermé dehors
et vous lui a cédé chose tir sur le fil
de fer qui se déroule monte attrape son
pic et soulève la tôle est dehors et se
trouve un peu plus loin nez à nez avec
une sentinelle vers sentinelle est ahuri
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est il faut
dire que la nuit est noire ya aucune
l'une au pin pad étoiles rien qu'est ce
que tu fais là dit la sentinelle et
l'autre moulures mais comment tu
reconnais pas dans glisse-t-on à hilla
sentinelle et aussi tous en profitant du
moment où il ya un grand coup pouce la
sentinelle dans l'escalier voit la
sentinelle qui roulent mais entre temps
d'arriver à essayer d'entrer il appelait
mon yahoo est immonde ya mon dieu mouly
avoué qu il monte l'escalier moulias
voulu à revient ballon mouly avec
d'étals dans la prairie vous pensez bien
la liberté
y'a encore plus que plus vite nous lie à
une curico échos et dans la nuit noire
une voix pas qu'au bout du prix d'un
énorme triage et tape dedans
il dira plus tard qu'il a tapé tellement
qu'il est bon dit comme un vallon alors
il prend son élan faut sauter le
grillage un élan aux îles le saut jamais
il n'aurait sauter 6 ou jamais eu non
plus sauter s'ils osent peut-être battu
le record du monde sur la elle relate
idée talent et on tire environ on le
rattrape et le voilà dans la nuit là pas
de chaussures
il est juste son pantalon et sa cheville
kurri kurri qu ils contournent tout le
village par le on redescend vers le
canal de l'aisne le canal de l'aisne là
y'a pont sur le canal de l'aisne il le
franches et parce qu'il sait que le
pourrait pas garder mais là au delà du
canal c'est un canal latéral
donkey allen après et là le pont garder
deux sentiments il sait qu'il peut pas
passer alors entre le canal et l'aisne
il ya un marcal avec des roseaux écho
dans ce marécage s'enfonce dans l'eau
s'accroupit entre les roseaux
personne ne peut le voir la nuit noire
je le rappelle est il entend un peu plus
tard la patronne qui arrive en courant
cherche partout ni vis ni koné la nuit
s'avance l'homme et tout à coup au loin
une salve dans le silence de la nuit
et puis à intervalles rapprochés trois
coups de feu le coup de grâce est tout à
coup chez moulia une immense tristesse
une lassitude immense le copain
mais pourquoi 3 parce que cordonnier
mondiale sera plus tard a été gracié au
dernier moment la nuit la journée encore
peut pas passer la nuit encore alors te
mais il faut passer il peut pas rester
là ils mangent uniquement des touches de
rose aux api de l'oseille qui est là il
boit l'eau du canal et décide de passer
le pont tant pis on verra bien
en pleine nuit il avance il ya la
première guérite à l'entrée du pont une
sentinelle il s'approche à mesure qu'ils
s'approchent dans la nuit il entend tout
à coup un ronflement sonore elle dort la
sentinelle il passe il s'avance vers
l'autre extrémité du pont et dans
l'autre guéri tient une bougie qui brûle
il se dit bon je vais passer va me tirer
dessus mais moi je veux faire des
zigzags
peut-être qu'ils m'attrapent rappaz
s'avance et bien vous vous croirez si
vous voulez mais c'est vrai
l'autre sentinelle d'un rossi et il
passe il a jamais eu autant de chance
dans sa vie
muglia et le voilà qui courent la
campagne toujours avec les pieds en
chaussettes qu'il allait payer
maintenant rempli de sang risque et
aucune importance on a pas mal dans ces
cas là il va frapper une porte à
appartenir à un petit village où je suis
allé aussi jolis villages les plus jolis
villages que j'ai vu et là il va frapper
à la porte
une dame qu'il connaît madame
charpentier elle ouvre elle le regarde
imaginez dans quel état ces deux jours
et deux nuits dans les roseaux sa
chemise sans pantalon les pieds nus elle
le regarde comment c'est vous monsieur
molia oui madame charpentier c'est moi
cash et moi il me cherche il vont me
tuer bon retrait monsieur moulin il
rentre vous avez faim en oui madame
alors une assiette de soupe deux
assiettes dessous trois assiettes de
soupe en une en or et manger mais elle
le cache dans un réduit et elles
accumulent des fagots de vent il va
passer la journée là et le soir elle
vient le dit monsieur ollier à vous
savez il ya pleins de soldats dans le
village et puis tout le monde parle de
votre évasion
on ne parle même que de ça alors il faut
partir
c'est trop dangereux il repart dans la
nuit et où va-t-il aller ben il a une
idée pourquoi pas aller vers les lignes
y'a pas sa vie molia dans les lignes
alors il arrive dans les lignes une
tranchée justement c'est l'art la vie
pour offrir de la relève il rentre dans
la tranchée puis dans une casemate petit
dans un abri plus tôt il aperçoit un sac
il louvoie ya une vieille tunique et une
capote
puis un peu plus loin les brodequins
miracle c'est brodequins lui vend puis
un peu plus loyer un fusil un mousqueton
il le prend et le voilà parti ou va-t-il
aller bailly à paris pourquoi pas paris
moi j'ai une tante qui est conscient de
l'année de bretagne qui allaient à paris
elle me cachera l'attend ces grands
pareil on ne trouvera pas dans paris
mais il faut franchir le canal de l'oise
allen elle allait dans les sentinelles
vont pas dormir ça se refait pas deux
fois
un coup pareil des camions bah oui il ya
une rotation de camions du monde dans un
camion il franchit le canal après
continue à pied alors ils marchent
pendant huit jours c'est à dire qui
marche la nuit et qui dort le jour pour
qu'on leur père pas ils mangeraient sais
même pas comment il a mangé une fois il
a osé en contrant un détachement
militaire
il a osé faire la queue au milieu des
soldats étant de sa gamelle qu'on lui a
rempli seul seul repas qui le fais
vraiment autrement n'importe quoi huit
jours pavillons-sous-bois un tramway
il monte dans le tramway et le voilà à
la gare de l'est et de la demande son
chemin pour l'avenue de breteuil on le
lui indique aux dix sept îles entre il
frappe à la porte vitrée de la concierge
une femme apparaît il faudrait par la
mamounia lé pa la malle à mollir je suis
son neveu elle est pas là madame aux
liens et les parties voilà molly à l'ats
beat plus ici mais où est ce que la vie
alors on ne sait pas on ne sait pas et
elle referme la vérité c'est qu'en route
mouly avait écrit à sa tante en lui
disant j'arrive et qu'elle avait pris
peur la bonne femme elle n'avait pas
voulu se montrer alors plus de tentes où
aller le pays pourquoi pas le pays et
par pour le pays pour le pays c'est la
gare d'austerlitz il arrive à la gare
d'austerlitz se mêlent à des
permissionnaires basque
il n'est pas contrôlé parce qu'il n'est
pas
c'est avec eux au milieu d'eux ils
roulent toute la journée par le train à
la nuit tombée ils arrivent dans un
petit village à buglose près de dax est
il décent parce qu'il préfère descendre
là en pleine campagne qu'à dax parce
qu'à dax et du contrôle puis a pas de
contrôle à buglose buglose c'est un
petit village à côté de la maison natale
de saint vincent de paul à côté de son
chêne qui est un lieu de pèlerinage et
vous lie à marchent marchent à l'aube il
est à dax et le court tout de suite là
où habite le père de berthe qui
travaille pour l'armée
le père de berck your comment c'est toi
mais tu es fou tout le monde le cherche
les gendarmes tout le monde est témoin
quand même à vélo pour aller en assiette
pas de vélo
on va te prendre on va reconnaître le
vélo serait complice va tamoul ya 20 ans
voilà qui repart à pied 40 km l'assiette
la nuit la maison de sa mère ils
frappent la voix de sa mère c'est toi
joseph
elle le prend pour sans frais oui dit
mooly à la maire monique guillou qui le
voit vincent quel temps comme une masse
sur le carreau elle va le cacher bien
sûr dans le four que là pendant des
semaines elle va le cacher et puis
berthe et avertit berdier le voir à la
nuit tombée peut pas résister la petite
berthe qu'il ya des gens qui la voient
la nuit alléché à la mer molia mais on
commence à bavarder bon allez faut
partir molia il va se cacher dans les
bois
il construit une cabane il s'installe un
jardin ça dure ça dure et puis un beau
jour un type le voit est à la tête du
type folie a comprend qu'il va le
dénoncer à leurs pertes et avertit
bareback cours chez l'abbé bernier chez
le curé qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
monsieur le curé bon il faut qu'il parte
tu es tout arranger des la baie je lui
donnais une carte une boule salive faut
qu'il passe en espagne et molia pas sans
espaces malgré les patrouilles saint
sébastien il y est ça y est
sauf ya juste un an que la mutinerie
elle lieu à béziers pipe berthe le
rejoint et puis l'abbé verrier qui fait
l'abbé verdier
fait le voyage ah bah oui parce qu'il
tient à être le label verdier ils vont
se marier ses deux enfants alors c'est
moi l'avait verdier qui veut les mariés
pas question que ce soit un autre et la
porte même les alliances alors il fait
sa vie en espagne où les les enfants
viennent
il ya du travail mais il pense toujours
à cette histoire de masi ils n'arrivent
pas à s'habituer à cette histoire c'est
quand même pas juste pourquoi que ça
m'est tombé sur moi comment des choses
pareilles peuvent arriver
c'est pas possible puis 1933 le
parlement vote l'aministie bon il peut
quand même rentré chez lui et pourtant
il reste à saint-sébastien bons ailiers
et du travail les gosses et c'est la
guerre d'espagne qu'il chasse voilà de
retour en assiette
on l'accueille bien et puis dans la rue
un voisin qui le regardent qui vient à
lui qui dit un mot là c'est moche
la guerre et il est tout saisi où il ya
parce qu'il n'y avait pas pensé
et il a raison le voisin et répète oui
c'est vrai c'est moche la guerre alors
les enfants grandiront partir 11
marieront ils auront eux mêmes des
enfants vincent et bertoia sont allé
habiter à londres et dans la petite
maison de berthe
ils ont vieilli amnistiés ou immo lien
mais pas réhabiliter pourtant tout
l'amicale du 18e a pris sa cause à coeur
on a fait des démarches
les officiants témoignant dimanche enfin
c'est pas possible il faut que molia
soit réhabilité et le capitaine lasserre
qui est mort au val-de-grâce souhaitait
plus que personne que moulias soit
réhabilité il a fait venir l'un de ses
anciens camarades
nicole et lui a dit nicole de mourir
mais reprenait la sphère en main il faut
réhabiliter mollien réhabiliter paraît
que c'était pas possible pourquoi parce
que même s'il était amnistié pour faits
de mutinerie il avait déserté alors il
aurait fallu qu'ils reviennent à son
corps avant la fin de la guerre revenir
à son corps avant la fin de la guerre
pour être fusillés
parce que c'est sérieuse que c'est
sérieux
station quelquefois alors oui les ai vus
là tous les deux berthet vincent moulin
en 1952 monsieur pierre de chevigné
ministres de secrétaires d'état à la
guerre a rendu sa carte de combattant
moulin il à sartène du combattant et moi
pendant que j'étais assis à sa table
merci pour le bon repas monsieur m
mollien je regardais la veste de vincent
mollien
je regardais la boutonnière elle est
vierge la boutonnière ya rien à la
boutonnière
alors je pose la question qui va prendre
l'initiative de réparer définitivement
une grande faute qui va rendre sa croix
de guerre
avensan moulis
[Musique]